hi everyone hi um alright um who uses
Linux so many people um who's excited
that there's this piece of open-source
software that makes your computer work
at least mostly
awesome um who feels like if they needed
to change that software so that it did a
new thing or did something differently
they would totally know where to start
and they know where to start learning
about that some of you maybe you all
should be in a different talk cuz that's
what I'm going to talk about um so um
I'm Julia um I work who works as like a
systems programmer on like low-level
stuff all the time some of you who
mostly writes like Python or like a
higher-level language and it's like
operating systems I'm not totally sure
me too
oh sweet um so in the fall of this year
a year ago I went to do a program called
hacker school and at hacker school the
goal is to like become a way better
programmer so like I was a programmer
and I'd like you know I wrote some
Python and I was like what's the
scariest thing I could do um and and
then I started learning about like the
Linux kernel and about operating systems
and I like riddles small operating
system and I'm going to talk about that
later
um and what I found out was that I
thought that like this Linux kernel
stuff was totally impossible and that I
could never learn it and that people
like like like Sarah sharp or and like
valor or who are like actual kernel
hackers who work on file systems and
stuff um we're magicians but um I turned
out that I could actually learn some of
it and the other thing that really
surprised me
um was that like once I learned this
stuff it actually became useful in like
my regular boring programming life
writing Python code would you expect
that who would expect that not you not
me um so I want to convince you two
things in this talk um one is that like
this kernel of programming stuff is
something that you could conceivably
learn about and the second is that like
maybe you should do it even if you don't
want to be a kernel developer because I
still I remained like a non kernel
developer for the record
um so where we're going step one like
what even is a colonel when I say that
word what does that mean um - why should
you care and like how will this be
useful to you in your regular life and
then I'll talk about like six strategies
for getting started with colonel
programming at sort of various levels of
commitment from like running one command
on your computer sometimes like doing an
entire like three month internship so um
this is only going to be about Linux um
like operating system stuff is kind of
the definition of platform-specific many
of these concepts carry over to like OS
10 or other unix's but I'm not going to
be talking about them I use Linux I
don't know so what is the kernel right
so the first thing that kind of helped
me out is I was like okay it's a lot of
code like there's a bunch of code that
some people wrote um and like let's say
I go to a website I go to google.com and
the kernel code is like fundamentally
mostly about like communicating with
your hardware and doing other low-level
things um so when I type in the address
for google.com I'll like press a key on
my keyboard and then there will be like
this like keyboard interrupt that runs
and some kernel code will be like okay I
figured out the key and then it'll like
send the information about the key to
the appropriate place so that like the
key can eventually appear on my screen
after a long a lot of stuff um the
tcp/ip is implemented in the kernel so
it handles all of the network packets
um I knows all about networking and
knows about like if I want to connect to
a server on a port it knows how that
works if I want to write like some like
history files the disk the colonel knows
a about like I have this hard drive in
my computer and there needs to be bytes
written on to that hard drive and like I
don't know how to do that the colonel
knows it's on it um and also like even
if I knew how to write those bytes to my
hard drive I don't know how they're
organized into file systems so like file
system limitations are in the kernel it
knows about allocating memory it handles
a whole bunch of memory management and
make sure that if you have a process and
another process but like one process
can't like spy on them and I mean the
other process it deals with a lot of
security um
if I have like a graphics card it will
communicate communicates with all your
hardware right which is why sometimes
your wireless card doesn't work but
maybe you could read the kernel code to
fix it I don't know um okay so that's
the kernel um one thing that really
confused me was like what's like how
would I call kernel code like what's the
interface so there are these things
called system calls system calls are
like the API for your operating system
or like we have like api's for like
flickr system calls are for your
operating system
so what that means is that the kernel
provides a whole bunch of functions that
you can call um to do things um every
time you open a file there's a system
call called open that gets called if you
want to start a program there's a system
call for that called exec ve if you want
to change the files permissions if you
want to send data over the network
if you cut like anything that kind of
requires communicating with the outside
world or like with your computer
you need to use a system call um so
we've learned so far this is all we need
to know about the current low-pro this
talk by the way
so does tons of stuff and your programs
tell it what to do using system calls um
so why should you care what is that like
if you're like oh yeah I heard of kernel
module for fine over the weekend people
be like wow and I don't know like maybe
I'll get dates I don't depending on like
who the kind of people who you date what
I don't know ah and like it's pretty fun
right like you feel like a wizard um but
I think there's a more important reason
which is that like it'll make you a
better programmer and that's what I'm
going to talk about for the next little
while so um and we're gonna talk about
like using this like systems knowledge
and like what is a system call to debug
your regular programs so s trace
esterase look legit my favorite thing
I've written like 7 blog post about
esterase and like I've written s trace
on the bus like I really like Esther IC
o---- let's talk about what Esther is so
when you're usually debugging what I do
is I'll be like writing a Python program
and it'll have a bug right like let's
say it's opening a file and like it's
not really opening the right file
like maybe I like concatenate some
strings wrong or like maybe I just
forgot to open it like I don't know
right so I might look at the source code
or I might like put a print statement in
front of the open to try to see what the
file name I opened was right or I could
like use a debugger and in particular
usually when you're debugging you need
to know the programming language that
you're writing is that true yeah um not
with s trace um with s trace oh no weird
a little you're a wizard you don't need
to do any of that stuff
um because what s trace does is it tells
you which system calls your program is
calling as it runs um so this is like
wizardry um so the way you run s trace
super simple this only works on Linux on
OS tens different things like D tress
you run like s trace Google Chrome and
it serves printing out like a whole
bunch of stuff I can maybe show you some
of the stuff because it's a little
overwhelming and I want you to be
prepared for that so it kind of looks
like that like it's like this and you
then you ignore most of it I'm to be
clear ah
and that I open Google Chrome which I
didn't wanna do right um the first thing
that you see when you start Google
Chrome is you start Google Chrome
it runs exec ve and it starts Google
Chrome surprise and then it starts doing
some like library stuff and it's looking
for like slash it sees like LDS oh no I
don't know
um and didn't find it ok so let's say I
want to know like I have the suspicion
that Google is spying on me and I want
to know which files in my home directory
its opening just to be sure that's not
actually something I think but I might
write um so I can look at what it's
opening and I'm like oh it like opens
this consent to sends that file like
what's that um I don't know and I can
look in it and I can see like oh there's
this big key right so like now I know
that apparently I've consented and like
it thinks but I don't know this is
probably fine probably
another thing that chrome does when it
runs is it'll spawn a whole bunch of
child processes like these sandbox
processes um and apparently one thing it
does is it calls this chrome sandbox
with an enable crash report option with
that key from that bio so if like
learned about something that Google
Chrome does just despite not reading any
source code we're like really knowing
anything about google chrome um so like
that's something right that's kind of
cool um something else I like to do with
s trace is I was trying to understand
like I work with Hadoop and with HDFS
which is this distributed file system
and I was like oh I have a distributed
file system and like how does it work I
don't really get it so I had this client
for the file system which could like
list things and cat files so I started
using s tricks just by own like its
network activities um to see what like
what it was sending and receiving um to
the to the clients um so I would s trace
it and then it would be like oh I'm
connecting to like ten point one four
seven point one seven seven point one
seven zero on fort 9200 um and then it
would send like these identifiers like
BP 101 933 and I was in the middle of
the investigations actually meant
something to me and I thought it was
cool ah just try to imagine that's like
useful information if you're using HTTP
that'll show you like garbage because
it's encrypted and hopefully what it's
sending over the wire is encrypted if
you're using HTTP right um
and then I got data back and I could see
like the English from like the Wikipedia
files that I had stored in my like file
system um in s trace and that was cool
um so um s trace was the best sometimes
I lose my log files and it's like you
have this program and it's writing to
some log files and you're like where
like a you read the documentation you
don't understand and may be stored in a
configuration file s trace will just
tell you right like Esther he's like
straight talk um right so you're like
what so my first day of work at my job
um I work at stripe um we were using
some like Ruby script which was running
some stage command and looked through
like and you have to like read
Ruby code we were having a problem and
we would have had to like read the Ruby
code understand then we s traced it and
it was like oh this is the SSH command
it's running and we could try it out
without having to like redo because like
if you don't want to read code right it
takes so much time you can use it to
debug like um like library problems when
your program is running the wrong
library like okay just tell me what
library you're really trying to run so I
can like delete it like I'm actually
just a League at the library um you know
when you can find your log files so
essays are the best um there's a warning
about s trace um
don't ruin s trace on like your
production processes that you really
need to go fast because what Esther days
does is it's like you want to make a
system call I'll put a huge like stop
sign in front of that system call and
log it um so it makes your process is
like way slower obviously um so like be
careful of that esterase s trace
responsibly um so this is the first part
of like understanding your operating
system makes you a better programmer um
but there's more so this is really cool
tool called perf um there was this great
talk earlier today about benchmarking
and about how like sometimes when you
have them you know you have a process
which is doing some really intensive
like numerical computations or something
I'm something really CPU intensive and
you want to make sure that like the data
they're they're these different levels
of CPU caches like l1 l2 l3 and you
might want to know if you're like doing
like hardcore optimizations of some like
inner loop um how many like l1 cache
misses you're having right and I used to
think like all this like stuff about CPU
I can never learn this but you totally
can like I wrote a program with like a
good 'not that good memory access
pattern where like took an array and
just like read the whole thing like in
order and it was like misses are like
eleven percent of the time it misses and
like uh it misses a ten percent as it
hits right which is great and then I
made a program that was designed to be
really bad where I was like take this
big array and then just like jump around
all the time like this and add up the
numbers in a really silly order and then
like it was so much worse and the
program was so much slower and I could
see that is because of the l1 cache and
I was like wow it's like of a wizard
and that was really cool um and this is
like a facility that the kernel provides
and if you know more about the kernel
then you can do more debugging in this
way which is really great though this is
less of like a Python thing and more of
like a serious I don't know like yeah um
you can also make these really cool
graphs with for with the output of perf
where you look at like what kernel
functions it's calling in case you're
doing some like really intense debugging
um which I almost never have occasion to
do but sometimes I talk people who do um
and then you're like really a wizard
because you're like I found a problem it
was like inside a kernel function or
like I needed to understand the kernel
to do bike a problem um that's a bit
like Esther is like way easier um
F choice is pretty cool this is
something I haven't had occasion to use
yet but I want to tell you about it cuz
I thought it was awesome um so let's say
like you were doing like some kind of
network application and you had like I
don't know it's like big database thing
and it was doing a lot of TCP
retransmits I'm like it was sending
packets like packets were getting
dropped in and was sending them again
because like the networking stack is in
the kernel right um so if you wanted to
do that there's a tool called F trace
which lets you like instrument like
specific kernel functions and like see
like when that function gets called
which is something that you could do
another favorite thing I have is /proc
who knows about /proc some of you many
of you um did you know that you can use
slash frog to like get rid of to get
deleted files back in some cases do you
want to do it let's do it it'll be fun
so let's see can you see this no let's
make let's make a bigger bigger house
this okay I made this program called
smile um it prints out smiley faces aha
uh that wasn't the exciting right guys
um so um let's say now that I delete the
executable it's gone do you think we can
get it back we can and we will
um so uh so this is um the executable
like for that file and it says deleted
but just because it's deleted it doesn't
mean you can't cat it uh-huh
so now let's get it back and let's like
stop the process now um and let's make
it executable and let's run it um also
if like a process you've deleted a file
that a process has open you can look at
like uh you can look at all of the files
that any process open let me like grip
Chrome so you can see what files are
miles open yeah so chrome has all these
files within like I don't know like
Chrome 100% pack I don't really know
what any of this is um but if like one
of those files were deleted while chrome
still had it open you could recover it
in this way because like if a process
has a file open being deleted doesn't
like her date until the file is closed
and you can get it back and it's not
just like a imaginary thing like you
could theoretically get it back you'd
really get it back um so that's cool
right that was the slide right so like
they're they're kind of like various
ways in which like understanding your
operating system makes you a better
programmer I hadn't went to like
alternate titles for this talk like
treat your programs is a black box and
just like imagine that like some like
malicious person wrote them and like use
like operating system tools to test them
like esterase to be like I don't trust
that like anything I believe about this
program is true let's just like look at
what it appears to be doing and debug
based on that
another thing is like you're offering
like we spend a lot of time building
tools and thinking about tools I'm often
programming language specific tools but
like your operating system as a tool and
it's sort of like an old tool and it's
not always like documented in an
accessible way um but it has a lot of
really powerful things in it and it's
something that you can learn um so who
wants to learn about it let's learn a
few things or let's see like strategies
to learn um so when I started this I
liked my understanding of how you
learned about Linux is that like you
would like look at the Linux kernel
mailing list and maybe like submit a
patch and your patch would be bad and
someone would yell at you and then you
would go cry look uh I like lettuce
might be a totally like this isn't about
lettuce ah but like this was like
basically how I thought it worked and I
went to this like IRC channel called
kernel newbies where people were
supposed to be nice and they were like
why would you want to learn about the
Linux kernel and I was like this is
called kernel newbies you're confused at
what channel you're in oh and then I
like felt that and then I went back to
doing things um so we're gonna have a
bunch of strategies that don't require
any like anyone to be nice to you you
can do them on your own
alright um so one strategy um and one of
my favorite things to do cuz I'm like a
huge s trace nerd now is to just s trace
things right like you cannot use it for
a program I'm like look at what system
calls is calling and like ignore almost
all of them
um and then be like oh why is it calling
that system call and sometimes like go
down a rat hole me okay I don't
understand never mind
but sometimes it'll totally make sense
like if you look at how kill-all is a
program which will kill all of the
programs with all of the processes with
a given name and if you look at the
system calls that it calls it'll like go
through it will perfect lists /proc and
then it'll iterate through opening all
of these files in /proc and then like
every so often it'll kill one of them
and what it's doing is it's like opening
file so like see what the process name
is and then if it matches then it kills
it and it's super simple and you don't
need to plug
read the source code to see what it's
doing I did that on train from Montreal
to New York where it was like really 13
hours long and I think like eight hours
and I was just started like s chasing
things oh because there is no internet
like it wasn't working and like they
like anyway like they came by being like
you broke another toilet guys it was
like anyway but we all survived we made
it to Montreal um right um so another
thing you can do is you can read some
like of a code in the Linux kernel like
it's open source and it's kind of
intimidating not all of it is totally
inaccessible um like so one thing that I
try to do sometimes it's like pick a
system call because we know about system
calls kind of and try to end gen like a
thing about that system call and they're
these really great tools like searches
through the Linux kernel um let's see if
the internet is working it seems like
highly unlikely but if I search like
Julia I can find out like all instances
of Julia and the Linux kernel or I could
look for like chmod um yeah so like this
is a really cool tool that you can use
to like grab the Linux kernel really
fast um so um I found this function
which appears to implement chmod there's
too much code here so I this thing I do
where I just use like eraser eyes I
ignore most of the code so what this is
fundamentally kind of doing is it um
takes a path and a mode and then it like
creates a lock and then it changes the
mode and then unlocks it like that's
like does that seem like logical to you
sort of um um and then we could like
potentially try to understand the rest
of this function um another thing you
can do if you want to kind of like
understand what's going on with the
Linux kernel um is there's a site called
Linux weekly news or lwn and they have
articles about like new updates and you
could read them be like I don't
understand almost everything but like
maybe you'll eventually you'll
understand some things like it's fun and
some of the articles are really
well-written there's really cool one I
bet like btrfs which is this file system
sometimes they have like overviews
whichever in like a more accessible way
and it's cool sight oh this is the fun
part this is where we play music I
promised you music so another really fun
thing to do is if you want to write code
for the kernel
like modify lit external is pretty hard
because you have to kind of understand
how it works but you can write what's
called a kernel module where you add
your own code onto the kernel and do
something fun so we're going to do
something fun so we talked about system
calls right um and we talked about the
open system call and it's like if you
wanted to play a prank on one of your
friends what have you changed the open
system call to do something different
like a little bit different so um let's
see what happens so this is what I
listen to it I program right okay um oh
no how do I stop it thank you
that wasn't even supposed to be a joke
okay
oops um okay right so so I have this
module called rickroll um and so let's
see what happens when we enable this
kernel module and so like anytime we
open a file
okay that's enough
oh um right so let's see how this works
also I can remove it um just to be safe
and now we're back to like okay great
I'm now we have Rihanna back and we can
code again right um so the way that a
kernel module works is it as its super
simple it has two functions the first
function is an init function which runs
when you run in smart the second one is
the clean up function which runs when
you're on RM bot um and so the way you
write a kernel module is you like to
find both those bugs you make a new
stuff and like the difficulty isn't the
stuff obviously but like making a low
kernel module is surprisingly like super
easy
um using to figure out head make compile
which I found surprisingly approachable
so the way this one works um
I should need to give some credit here
actually the way I do not write this
current no module what happened is my
friend Tavish was like you're giving a
talk about the Linux kernel you should
make one that Rick rolls everyone um and
I was like oh yeah and then my amazing
partner Kemal was like all that sounds
like fun
can I write it and I was like of course
you could write it so he read it and he
did a really awesome job and it's like
really well documented and if you read
it it's fun um right so the way this
works
um its first like you look up the system
call table um and then you find the
original open system call and you save
it away and then you replace the
original open system call with your new
system call called Rick roll open and
when you clean up you put the original
open function back it's pretty simple um
there's some other stuff which is all
like explain to the source and the way
that um this Rick roll open function
works is their stuff and then we erase
some of the stuff and basically all it
does is it has like the file name of the
file - okay um and then if it's not an
mp3 you just leave it alone because you
don't want to like return Rick Astley
for Olive Oyl
because that was probably not end well
like I don't know what would happened to
my system Oh
and I'm not sure I wanted to find out um
and then if it is an mp3 then you just
go ahead and you pass the rickroll file
name instead onto the open system call
um
and then you're done okay um that's all
the code in this talk I think um cool so
um and not another thing you can do is
you can write your own operating system
which sounds like a really bad idea
because operating systems are really
complicated
um the cool thing about writing your own
operating system um is that it doesn't
have to do anything like it doesn't have
to work um so I read an operating system
and I'm going to show it to you um let's
see hopefully it'll work it runs in a
virtual machine for like reasons that
will become clear so um what um what
this does I want you to watch really
closely is I press the letter J on my
keyboard it appears on the screen and if
I press other letters those will also
appear so it like understands how a
keyboard works
um that was my that took three weeks but
it was really good project cuz I learned
a lot of things like I wrote like this
post called like after I think it was
actually five days I can finally press a
key on my keyboard without like the
operating system totally crashing um it
took a long time I also have a post got
like why so I offer existent being
deleted of Austria it wasn't actually I
just didn't understand boot loaders but
it took me like five days to figure it
out um I learned so many things
um and then like I like actually
interviewed for like kernel developer
jobs afterwards and they would like
interview me which was really surprising
and then they were like wait you don't
know a lot of that I'll bring some times
I was I was like you wanted to interview
me like this is clearly your problem not
mine you read my blog and decided this
was a good idea
um so another strategy you can use is
this challenge that I don't know how to
pronounce the name of um that's the name
of it um has anyone done the Matis I
know crypto challenges um some of you
what they are is there a series of
challenges to help you understand better
like how to do cryptography right or
wrong so they have you like implement a
bunch of crypto algorithms and then
break them and then implement better
ones that break those and then implement
better ones and break those um and it's
really fun um and this is like a series
of like progressively harder kernel
challenges for getting started with like
and the first challenge like write a
hello world kernel module which is
pretty easy I haven't done them but my
friend Alex told me he did them and that
they were hard but like possibly doable
the last strategy that you can do is
there are some internships to work on
the Linux kernel but you can do as long
as you sort of know likes em see like
the they start out being like there's a
there's like some inconsistent style in
the kernel and like fix like make it
conform to the real style so like the
patches you start out with our super
simple in the application um um there
are two internships I know about there's
google Summer of Code if you're a
student which is in the summer there's
also the no mater each program for women
which is the super great mentorship
program where you get paid to work a
five thousand dollars to work on an
open-source project for three months
applications for the average programmer
women are open right now if you like
suddenly really want to be a kernel
hacker you could be like the application
process is cool you actually like
semitic patch to the kernel as part of
the application process um and like you
need to send like email i'm the hardest
part is sending email um
because like you do not just email
kernel mailing goes apparently you need
to email them in very specific ways um
but there's like a detailed tutorial on
how to send email to the mailing goes in
the correct way
um they explains you how to do it and
there are a whole bunch of mentors to
help you out and there's like I think
like the kernel like Linux kernel
emailing those seems like a scary place
so there's a special outreach program
for women mailing list which is a less
scary place and they'll like
a patch review for you so you'll send
out your patch and be scared and then
they'll like help you figure out how to
make it right um the deadline is October
31st they do their I think in the last
batch there is a super cool project
we're like so imagine if your kernel
crashes and you want to print an error
message the problem with like your
kernel crashing is you can no longer
like right stuff to disk right cuz the
kernel is gone like you can't do a lot
um so like you would have to like I
think people have to like coffee stuff
off the screen manually which is a huge
pain so there's this project to like
print QR codes to the scream it's like
the best idea for QR codes that have
ever seen so that you didn't people
didn't have to like take a picture or
something um just pretty cool um that's
most of what I have to say um so like
after I did all of this I felt like like
I'm still not like a magical kernel for
a camera right like I still only know a
few things um but I really feel like I
could be a kernel programmer if I wanted
to be because now I know where to start
um and I think that you could be - ah
that's all that's what I have to say
um
um if you want any of the things from
this talk I wrote like a three thousand
word blog post version of this talk on
my blog on which you could read um does
anyone have any questions I think we
have a few minutes like ten minutes yes
yeah yeah this one yeah sweet yes um
so yes if I used any books and the
answer is no I was too impatient um I
think that there are good books yeah I
was at hacker school and I just did
things and like the amazing facilitators
would help me out and I feel like things
don't work and they'd be like what
things have you tried just like they
were super nice yeah um is there
somebody yes how did you send Buckley
experiments so so I didn't recommend two
ways um the first ways I didn't uh-huh a
lot of my curled module experiments I
just read on my own machine and hope
that nothing bad would happen I don't
recommend that you can also use a
virtual machine I used a virtual machine
to develop my operating system because
otherwise it would've been really
annoying to reboot all the time yes how
it is running you're an OS compared to
writing your own bias or efi code um I
really don't know I would like you to do
it and report back yeah I like it
I've never done either of those things
oh yeah I don't know what they're like
are there more questions you can always
talk to me afterwards I like talking
about this stuff a lot cool
you